now to the war in ukraine the biden
administration is sending another 600
million dollars in military aid as the
country continues its counter-offensive
against russian forces president
vladimir zielinski said last night
russia leaves death everywhere deborah
patta is in the devastated northeastern
city of isiam captured by russia in the
early days of the war and liberated by
ukraine last week deborah good morning
good morning a grim discovery here in
isian behind me this forest is filled
with the bodies of dozens upon dozens of
civilians buried in shallow graves some
of them killed when russian tanks and
artillery rain down on this town others
executed
when russian forces came to israel they
laid waste to this town shelling
relentlessly for weeks before they had
full control hospitals and schools blown
up clearly not military targets many
were killed often buried in shallow
graves at mass burial sites
and then they attempted to erase every
trace of ukrainian identity
they burned our books destroyed our
schools removed our tv channels and put
on moscow's propaganda yulia kosyobenko
told us
and then there was the torture of anyone
with connections to the military
those who served in the security forces
were found she said taken away and
beaten in some cases even worse
but even harder to bear than the loss of
their culture and soul was the knowledge
that some amongst their midst had
betrayed them
julia's husband was one of them she's
denounced him as a traitor
my husband is working with the russians
and her son your husband's collaborating
with russians no even college naturally
he no longer exists for me she said i
found this
there were those who say they had no
choice but to take what russia gave them
like svetlana fisher who says their
mayor abandoned them
i couldn't leave nobody helped me she
said angrily now i'm a traitor because i
had to survive on russian rations but as
the full extent of russian atrocities is
revealed bitterness has turned to hatred
in isiam
for the people who brought death
to this town
over the next few days the grim task of
exhuming and identifying the bodies
begins
each victim here is loved by someone a
personal trauma for those who mourn them
and another national tragedy for war
crimes prosecutors to investigate for
cbs morning's debra pada ism ukraine